they're gonna run it down to the end
yeah do they get the last shot
you want to win it or go to overtime
oladipo
long shot he thrilled that pure magic
victor oladipo a little step back again
off a good defender and robertson knocks
it down
after payton cross court oladipo cannot
find an opening now fires
he got it he drilled it we're going to
another overtime
sends it to overtime number two about
this a little
fake and alfred payton along the
baseline
good close out of that first by roberson
wow
nice job by victor just creating a
little space kept his feet in bounds
and drilled it
smith hands it off to one of the depot
slings it over the
shoulder and it banked it in what a shot
by victor oladipo
says going to the rim earlier and so
this one why not
success breeds success the client
is a little out of control three on two
21st
[Applause]
alfred payton with the pretty lob for
victor oladipo right
on the money but he missed the shot
temple down court drives contact no call
you can see oladipo timing that getting
a running start and generating some
momentum
and here's the block on garrett temple
blizzard's up by four
fournier victor looking for some
daylight rising for three
with five seconds left played by walker
very well squares him up
victor trying to lean in maybe get some
contact
he shot that off the glass like he meant
to do that david steele
[Music]
wow again brandon doing the right thing
david the clock going down made a nice
play to the rim wow what a block by
oladipo
clock will barton again in the dunk
constant high riser
up at 128.
over depot and kent are looking to be
aggressive oh
i would say that's aggressive for victor
oladipo
touching the paint
in a tough situation or maybe not he
knew two or three guys were going to
come to him
so somebody like oladipo would be open
we take time
[Music]
oladipo finds the back door open and the
thunder has a three-point lead mid-first
quarter
you're watching thunder basketball on
fox sports oklahoma
turning curve sabonis is back with the
thunder
oladipo gonna streak and pack it
where'd he come from amazement you want
to see somebody on a pogo stick watch
this
boom you know who used to do dunks like
that he's in the building right now
he's one of the color analysts with
atlanta hawks basket
[Music]
with nine unanswered points and another
takeaway
over the top
westbrook setting up all the depot point
play
get numbers behind the basketball he's
got those eagle eyes he's never looking
at
the person he's gonna pass the ball to
this time his old depot who can play
above the rim
the thunder with more is sabonis who has
three
ole depot heaves and hits
victor oladipo beats the buzzer he
has 21 on the night
[Applause]
no doubt it was out of his hands in time
in a big bucket
now they have a chance to win the ball
game all the people off the bumper
[Music]
was able to get the basketball out front
waved everyone off
got the mismatch he wanted but ricky
rubio
[Music]
[Applause]
airborne this is the way they've been
playing
all night long westbrook has been on
target with his passes
oladipo with a sweet finish for the
thunder
[Music]
we have the good fortune to go to visit
uh with nba cares
and orphanage whoa look at victor victor
gets the first hoop
[Music]
[Applause]
that one was unbelievable i thought
darren collinson had thrown the ball
out of bounds play he just throws it and
victor just soars
to get that one i mean there's not many
people that would be impressed with that
like victory is because he knew
he had to go get it what a terrific play
and switched it 15 seconds to play
seven here's a three by oladipa oh
he hit it victor on a default from
three-point and the pacers have a
one-point lead
he's got aldridge out there shot clocks
at five and going down
and he knocks it right down able to get
it over the top
marcus cousins has left he has two fouls
that's why he's out as oladipo went
right around cunningham really powerful
move to get to the rim
and you can see the explosion here not
only quickly but to the other side of
the rim
over anthony davis who came late victor
oladipo was able to finish strong
all-star break last year now in his
first year here in memphis oladipo
beats brooks into the half court puts it
up yeah
yeah bases had a lot of good offense
going there in that first half
victor oladipo goes coast to coast and
buries the shot
at the buzzer and the pacers have a
double figure halftime lead
in memphis a point oladipo leads the
break
as hit two threes finds turner
pounds it home what a great no-look pass
left-handed turner young maganovic
and kovason valentine's
shot clock in the morning falls against
the oladipo the stealth rush
here's all the defaults for the lead
the san indiana spurs comes up with the
loose ball
one of the best in the league early in
transition
threes and the pacers with 30.1 to play
lead 97-96
[Music]
ended his career all packed well again
here's all the deals indeed
on a great cut ron they have their
largest lead
they never led in the first half oladipo
has
28 and the pacers lead it 88 85.
reggie's got five pounds but pistons
need offense right now fish to the
basket
blocked by old depot in the first half
he was found on a three-point shot
oh look at all the depot how about the
pass
that's glad stevenson through
you can see that this is playing and
maybe there's eye contact made and then
you just throw it at the rim and let
victor oladipo get it but
lance throws it right where it needs to
be this guy's a good defensive
you got to know it that's why you got to
move the ball but you got to move it
move it sharply gets inside what a shot
by vic
i'm telling you that's some shot for
sure because i didn't think he hit
he not only do get his set up cleanly
but watch it's four
he gets it up off the glass nicely
actually three he
i think he comes back over the head
right-handed off the glass
that was on white side that's his board
[Music]
it's the third team foul against the
heat it really has but fortunately
it's been a challenge for the pacers to
score too but their defense has been
there
victor's working on his showman game i
mean
he made an all-star game pass
picks up the dribble howard working
against the 21 year old turner
the
the post of mkg on the previous
defensive possession
perfect timing look how high he is up
we're in a triple double in his first
career start on the depot
[Music]
[Applause]
a 7-0 run the first time all-star
made six threes the knicks have made
five
nice job by victor oladipo he won't get
a steal
but he'll get the gunk on a nice 360
happen this is just so unselfish play
and then lance puts on a little bit of a
show
as he's preparing for the all-star game
dunk contest
you might see that one and now a three
from turner
short but robinson the rebound you got
to see yeah
yeah i wasn't sure he saw the defense
behind him
he's hunting a triple double tonight
just 10 points
but seven rebounds and nine assists
for the pacers number four indiana by
19.
and it's a tough shot i mean he's trying
to shoot a three-point shot he hadn't
made him
oh he threw it through the legs of
middleton a three
by but donovan yeah hilton was jumping
up
because he'd come out of the corner for
one that
you'll see right there gets it through
there
pacers get a three-pointer out of get a
little bit of run here up
seven double to ucla bruins holiday
gets to the paint and battered away what
a block biola depot
collison going to the line looking for
the three-point play to tie things up
wow no step
just i'll meet you at the top oh he's
serious athlete
let it go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how about that one play really well
everybody knows you're the guy on the
team that should take the shot
victor's able to clear space and knock
it down you can see
the zero beautifully for the pacers this
year what terrific ball handling there
oh my goodness shake them up
[ __ ] shake him up [ __ ]
oh my goodness look he's down in the
stands and you can see
cook kid gilchrist can't get his feet up
in time to do anything watch
oh excuse me oh take that with you in a
little hoop by
victor which is not the four shots and
she said victor's
off to a great start he can shoot it any
time he wants almost oh what a shot
biola depot he has 21.
here victor does a nice job faking
getting to the rim and
with dwight howard trying to be out
there where the screen is at that point
there's nobody that can block the shot
williams can only watch
[Applause]
on james stolen viola depot stevenson
back to oladipo
[Applause]
[Music]
shot clock at four oladipo harassed by
james
oladipo pulls back high locking great oh
he knocks him down
as the shot clock expires and a big
smile from ole tepo
nine seconds two on the shot clock chris
paul got it blocked
big guy just stood there tj leaf
[Applause]
and he banks in a three-pointer before
the buzzer
watch it one more time as oladipo just
throws it up and prays
loose
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a tough cover for him
[Music]
gets past the beach shuffle pass inside
and young
caps it off with a layup and brett brown
will use his
final timeout i got the mismatch i'm
gonna cross and go
and then a pinpoint pass he's done that
time and time again here in the last six
minutes of this game
see he has great vision and he's not
going to force a shot
and now with five seconds here's oladipo
three seconds
to win it yeah
way to raise the photo vic victory
way to race up with a huge overtime
three
but they send miles away because they
don't want the double team which is good
because state mcmillan did that
and right here vic just backs him up
shoots it a little long
dead dead on and it goes down now there
may be more than three tenths of a
second but at that point
who cares big knocked down the three
quinn victor oladipo since he has worn
the blue and gold of the pacers besides
felicio
it's six seven now olivia has it
hutchinson here's a long three by oh
you hear his back he's back
ladies and gentlemen mom approves you
know what
the real key to being a clutch player is
being willing to take what comes with it
another eight-point lead for the dallas
mavericks with 7.6
and oladipo a long three
good to get the fans into the game a
little bit here chris